it's always really hard for me to look
at photos of myself from before
i've kept this journal since i was 15.
i made a new friend
i'm here today to talk about brian
warner also known to the world as
marilyn manson
he studied how to manipulate people he
groomed her he's a predator everyone was
looking at marilyn manson and they
weren't looking at brian warner
numerous women heard my story and they
knew exactly who it was i realized that
i was the only one that this had
happened to
you're not alone
i know it's crazy
we were outside of the statute of
limitations we had run out of time and
nothing in our evidence could help us
statistically a lot of victims take
seven to ten years to even recognize
that they were a victim of this abuse
i became an activist fighting for
victims and survivors of domestic
violence and sexual assault
not only did people hear our stories but
they said yeah we hear you when
something does need to change any bills
that will expand the statute of
limitations is really important to
survivors like us
we need to make sure that this doesn't
happen to anybody else i realized that
this is the first time i haven't been
doubted or questioned or shamed this is
the first time that someone was really
listening
i was like what is this feeling and it's
this feeling of
being believed
[Music]
you